皆さんは
「オデッセイ」と言う映画をご存知でしょうか
実は私ですね
先日「オデッセイ」の試写会の方に
参加させていただきまして
一足先に「オデッセイ」の映画、見させていただきました。
よかった...
マジでよかったです...
主人公はその、宇宙飛行士なんですよ。
火星の探索みたいな感じで
ちょっと火星のほうに来ちゃってて
火星っていうのはねこうね
天候がすごい変わりやすくて
いきなりそのすっごい風が強くなったりして、
もういろんなことが起きちゃって
主人公だけがちょっと火星に取り残されちゃうんですよ
置いてかれて、助けが来ないかもしれないんスよ
そんな状況で彼はどのようにして火星で生き延びるか
僕の勝手な感想なんですけども
あの凄い植物学を学びたくなりました
主人公のワトニーがねその
植物学を専攻しててね、その
火星の土を使ってね、
ハッ！
これ以上はお楽しみだ
よく火星という-55℃の寒い空間で、
彼は何も無い所で生き延びてぁ
素晴らしい！
だが、俺も素晴らしいだろ？
まあ僕ぐらいまではまあ
ワトニーぐらいの力はあると思ってんで。
-55℃までとは行かないんですけども、
寒い厳しい環境でも多分僕は
生き延びれると思んスよ
特に役立つ物が置いていない場所に
僕は閉じ込められて、
生活してみようと思います。
きっと俺なら生き延びれる。
そう、助けが、来るまで。
これが今回の冷凍庫か。
レストランの裏とかにある
本格的な奴だな。
火星は-55℃に対し、
この冷凍庫は-30℃。
余裕だ。(キリッ)
ッハ―↑
寒いよぉぉぉぉぅ！
ハ――――
ハイ！
という訳で
僕はここからここで生活してみます。
火星に比べると全然楽なので、
大丈夫で～す
あっ！あんな所に！
カップラーメンと泥水が！
泥水じゃカップラーメンは作れないんですけど、
何か良い物は無いかな
あ"――っ！
こんな所に
色んなゴチャゴチャした物が！
これは何か火を起こす奴です多分。
火が、起きます。
炭とか。
あと木炭とか。
あれ、これは
ろ過装置か？
ちょっと、ろ過装置っぽい奴があるので、
これで、ちょまず泥水をちょっとろ過してみましょう。
そこからやってみます。
ろ過の仕方が良く分からない。
そうだ
電話でちょっと友達に聞いてみます。
あ"―――っ！
電波が無ぁぁぁぁい！
うおおおおお！
わぁぁぁはぁぁぁ！
では早速、泥水を
ろ過していこうと思いまぁぁぁぁ！
うわぁぁぁぁ！
わーっ！
これだけだと多分ならないので、
この中に多分何か入れると思います。
それがだんだんここに
あると、思いますので
ちょっと探してみようと思います
まずは小石だな。
小石をちょっと、この中に入れていこうと思います。
もう凍って、凍ってるよ
ひとまず、小石入れました。
ついに！
木炭を、この中に入れていきます。
次は
砂入れてきやす
砂。
この上に、布を被せていきます
でこの上に、泥水を入れてくと
ここに、キレイな水が出るかもしれません。
ああっ！
わぁっ！
キャ―――ッ！
わっ
わぁぁぁぁぁっ！
わはは―――ww
どうなるでしょうか
おおっ！えっ？透明
透明透明透明透明
えぇっ！？
透明ですよ！
すごい！マジで透明
あ、来た来た来た
おっけ、おっけ、おっけ
うわっ、すごい
こぼした水が凍ってる
あ、どうでもいいや
火を起こしていこうと思います
炭とか
火を起こす道具。
で、ティッシュとかも置いてるんで、
これをちょっと使って、
やっとうぁんざ――っ！
よっしゃぁぁぁ
点火、させます。
やってみましょう
ここで決まりますよ、ここ。
おっ、あっえっ、待って。
惜しい感じがしました
これで点けばいいんスけど
あっ、おっおっおっ。
来たァッ、来た。
はっ、来た
炭入れましょう
おっ、やった。あったかいよ！
えへやったちょっと待って。
良かったぁ
何とか、火も、安定してきて
ろ過の水も結構溜まってきました。
でこの、ろ過した水がまだちょっと汚いので
これでガチの飲むのが出来るんで、
これでもっかい透明になります。
早速沸かしていこうと思います。
お？来たんじゃないスかこれ！
来た来た来た
お湯、完成でございま～す
もう、スゴい
熱々レベル。
よしよしよしよしよしよ～し
では、いただきます。
えっ？
足りない。
カリッ
僕はもうボロ泣きするぐらい感動できたので
是非皆さんも見てほしいと思っております。
でですね、何か今ですね、
今何かキャンペーンで「オデッセイ」の何かこういう
植物が育てれるみたいです。
僕多分今人生やり直せるなら
多分農学部とか
植物学の事学びたいと思ってるぐらいなんですけども、
植物が育てられる
「オデッセイプラント」というのがあるみたいです。
これなんかねプレゼントで貰えるらしいので
これ育ててみたいと思う人
動画の説明欄から詳しい情報があるので
是非そちらからチェックしてみてください！
じゃあな！